>>> WHAT'S UP, EVERYONE, WELCOME
TO A SPECIAL DIVISIONAL ROUND
EDITION OF "THE SQUAD RIDE" LIVE
IN THE BLEACHER REPORT APP
PRESENTED BY DRAFTKINGS.
IF YOU WERE WITH US LAST WEEK,
SQUAD RIDE CASH, PATRICK MAHOMES
THREW FOR THE MOST PASSING
YARDS.
SHOUTOUT TO GREG, SHOUTOUT TO
THE SQUAD.
WE ARE RIDING HIGH RIGHT NOW,
AND WE HOPE TO DO IT AGAIN, AND
WE HOPE TO DO IT WITH YOUR HELP.
AND AS ALWAYS, GREG'S GOT A LOT
TO GIVE AWAY.
HE'S GOT THE HOODIES BUT THE
PLAYOFFS HIT A LITTLE DIFFERENT.
GREG, LET'S WELCOME YOU IN, AND
TELL THEM WHAT YOU GOT THIS
WEEKEND.
>> CONNOR, THE QUESTION OF THE
DAY IS, WHAT AREN'T WE GIVING
THE PEOPLE TODAY?
THAT'S THE QUESTION.
WE'VE GOT A CUSTOM ODDS BOOST
FROM OUR FRIENDS OVER AT
DRAFTKINGS, OVER A THOUSAND DK
DOLLARS WE'RE GIVING AWAY TODAY.
WE'VE GOT HOODIES, OF COURSE,
JERSEYS, AND A PAIR OF AIRPODS
MAXES, BRO, A PAIR OF AIRPODS
MAXES.
CONNOR, DO YOU HAVE A PAIR OF
AIR
AIR POD MAXES.
>> I DO NOT, GREG, WE'RE GIVING
AWAY THE GOOD STUFF, GIVING IT
AWAY, NOT KEEPING IT.
THAT'S THE KEY.
AIR POD MAXES ARE OVER THE YEAR,
WHICH WOULD SOLVE THE PROBLEM OF
THEM FALLING OUT ON THE SUBWAY
TRACKS AND NOT SEEING THEM
AGAIN.
WE SWITCHED IT LAST WEEK.
WE ASKED WHO IS THROWING THE
MOST PASSING YARDS.
WE'RE GOING BACK TO OUR ROOTS ON
DIVISIONAL WEEKEND.
IF YOU WATCHED THE SHOW ALL YEAR
WE KNOW THE DEAL, WE WANT TO
KNOW WHO ARE THE LOCKS TO GET IN
THE END ZONE, WE ASK YOU ON
SOCIAL, WE ASK YOU IN THE APP.
WHO'S SCORING.
IT'S THE PLAYOFFS, BABY, WHO'S
GETTING IN THE END ZONE.
THE MOST POPULAR PICKS YOU SENT
US, FEATURED ANYTIME TOUCHDOWN
ODDS, THE KING IS BACK, DEREK
HENRY, AT THE TOP OF THE BOARD,
MINUS 190, COOPER KUPP, AND
DAVANTE ADAMS, EVEN AT MINUS
135.
NO SURPRISE THERE WITH HOW
DOMINANT THOSE TWO HAVE BEEN.
WE KNOW WHAT GRONK DOES IN THE
PLAYOFFS, HOW MUCH BRADY LOVES
MIKE EVANS.
HE LOOKS FRESH AND READY TO GO
AND AJ BROWN, A REVITALIZED
ODELL BECKHAM JR.
BOY, IS HE HAPPY TO BE IN L.A.
WE HAVE FOUR LEGENDARY PICKS TO
SHOW YOU.
LAST ONE STANDING, SQUAD RIDE
LEADER.
THEY GET THE JERSEY, GREG IS
GOING TO BOOST THE ODDS.
WE'RE ALL GOING TO THROW SOME
CASH ON IT AND HAVE OURSELVES A
SATURDAY AND THEN A SUNDAY.
LET'S GET RIGHT INTO IT RIGHT
NOW.
THE FIRST ONE IS FROM MICHAEL
CALL A, WHO YOU PICKING TO SCORE
THIS WEEKEND?
>> WHAT TOOK SO LONG?
>> SORRY, BOSS, I'M COOKING UP
SOME LOCKS, BRO.
HERE'S YOUR PIZZA.
THIS IS FOR YOU.
AJ BROWN, ANYTIME -- SCORER,
TRUST ME ON THAT ONE, WE GOT
THIS.
>> MY LOCAL NORTHEASTERN
FRIENDS, GOING WITH A.J. BROWN,
HERE'S YOUR PIZZA.
ALL RIGHT, FIRST MATCHUP OF THE
WEEK IS COMING IN FROM AMARNZA
TAKING ON THE PIZZA LEGEND, SEE
IF IT'S ENOUGH TO KNOCK HIM OFF.
>> BOOK IT.
>> MY MAN IS IN A REAL LIFE
TANK, GREG, THAT IS A FIRST FOR
THE SQUAD RIDE.
COMING IN A COOPER KUPP.
SO WE'VE GOT A WIDE RECEIVER
STANDOFF IN THE FIRST ROUND,
GREG, LET HIM KNOW WHAT WE NEED.
I'M GOING TO ASK YOU, WHICH ONE
ARE YOU RIDING?
THIS IS A TOUGH OPENER WE'RE
STARTING WITH.
>> THIS IS A TOUGH ONE, BUT WHAT
I NEED EVERYBODY TO DO NOT
COMMENTS IS LET ME -- LET ME
FRIEND CONNOR, AND LET EVERYBODY
ELSE IN THE COMMENTS KNOW WHO
YOU ARE RIDING WITH, ARE YOU
TAKING A.J. BROWN, OR ARE YOU
TAKING COOPER KUPP?
CONNOR, THIS ONE'S TOUGH.
THIS ONE IS TOUGH.
A.J. BROWN, HIM AND RYAN
TANNEHILL, THEY'VE BEEN CLICKING
AS OF LATE.
THEY'VE BEEN CLICKING AS OF
LATE, PLUS 140 LOOKS LIKE GOOD
MONEY.
BUT I QUESTION.
I JUST QUESTION THEIR CHEMISTRY.
I JUST QUESTION IF THEY'RE GOING
TO CLICK TODAY BECAUSE THEY'RE
GETTING BACK DERRICK HENRY.
WHEN HE'S COMING BACK, I DON'T
KNOW HOW THEY'RE GOING TO GEL,
RUN THE BALL MAJORITY OF THE
DAY, PLAY ACTION, PASS THE BALL.
IT'S JUST A LOT OF QUESTIONS, SO
I'M GOING TO STAY AWAY FROM THE
A.J. BROWN PICK, AND I FEEL
SAFE.
I FEEL AS SAFE AS MATT STAFFORD
RIGHT NOW WHEN HE THROWS THE
BALL TO COOPER KUPP.
COOPER KUPP SITTING AT MINUS
135, CONNOR, YOU KNOW WHAT WE
CAN DO HERE.
I LIKE COOPER KUPP, MAN, HE'S
BEEN DOING IT ALL YEAR.
I LIKE -- I LIKE THE RAMS IN
THIS MATCHUP.
I'M TAKING COOPER KUPP, CONNOR.
WHICH WAY ARE YOU RIDING?
>> AND I LOVE TO HEAR THAT
BECAUSE I'M DOING THE SAME.
THE PLAYOFFS ARE ALL ABOUT
TRUST, RIGHT, I DON'T CARE ABOUT
THE ODDS.
IT'S GREAT THAT IT'S PLUS 140.
THAT'S WHY IT DOESN'T MEAN
ANYTHING IF IT DOESN'T HAPPEN.
I LOOK AT THIS.
I THINK MINUS 135 FOR KUPP IS
ACTUALLY REALLY NICE, ESPECIALLY
WHEN YOU TAKE INTO ACCOUNT WHERE
GREG'S GOING TO TAKE THOSE ODDS.
SO THE RAMS LOOK GOOD RIGHT NOW.
I THINK THEY MIGHT SURPRISE SOME
PEOPLE THIS WEEKEND.
AND EVEN IF THEY DON'T, WE KNOW
COOPER KUPP IS GOING TO GET HIS.
SO MINUS 135, AND SHOUTOUT TO
THE TANK LEGEND, RIGHT, WE HAVE
NOT SEEN THAT ONE BEFORE.
THAT GIVES YOU A LITTLE BOOST.
SO WE'RE GOING WITH KUPP, GREG,
WHERE ARE THE COMMENTS GOING?
>> LET ME HOP INTO THE HANDY
DANDY iPAD, FOR THOSE THAT DON'T
KNOW, THIS IS THE HANDY DANDY
iPAD, THIS IS HOW YOU GET
HOODIES, THIS IS HOW YOU WILL
GET JERSEYS, HOW YOU WILL GET
250 DK DOLLARS AND HOW SOMEBODY
WILL WALK AWAY WITH AIRPOD
MAXES, ALL HAPPENING RIGHT HERE,
I GOT O BEAST 800, SAYS COOPER
KUPP IS A LOCK.
SHOUTOUT TO YOU, YOU'RE WALKING
AWAY WITH A HOODIE.
I GOT MME 9 SAYS KUPP, HENRY IS
GOING TO GET THE YARDS AND TD,
SO HE'S ROCKING WITH COOPER
KUPP.
SHOUTOUT TO YOU, MME.
ONE MORE IN HERE, CONNOR, THE
COMMENTS ARE JUMPING.
I GOT S YOUNG 37 SAYS KUPP WILL
ERUPT.
I LIKE THAT.
I LIKE WHAT HE DID THERE.
SO CONNOR, I'M MAKING THE CALL.
COOPER KUPP IS MOVING ON TO THE
NEXT ROUND, BROTHER.
>> AND I LIKE IT, YOU KNOW WE'RE
RIDING WITH THAT ONE, A GOOD
CALL.
COOPER KUPP MOVING ON TO ROUND
TWO.
IT'S NOT OVER YET.
IN ROUND TWO, FAMILIAR FACE, BEN
MERRICK BRINGING IT THIS WEEK,
SEE WHAT BEN'S GOT COOKING UP
FOR US.
♪
>> THE RARE TEAMMATE STANDOFF
MATCHUP ON THE SQUAD RIDE,
COOPER KUPP, BUT HIS TEAMMATE
ACROSS FROM HIM, WHO'S BEEN GOOD
SINCE HE'S BEEN WITH THE RAMS IN
ODELL BECKHAM COMING IN AT PLUS
160.
BEN MERRICK, THE TOAST LEGEND,
GOING WITH OBJ.
ALL RIGHT, GREG.
BOTH RAMS.
WE LIKE WHAT THE RAMS ARE
LOOKING LIKE THIS WEEK AGAINST
THAT BUCS SECONDARY.
IS THIS ENOUGH TO SWAY YOU?
DO BOTH OF THEM SCORE?
WHERE ARE WE GOING HERE?
>> CONNOR, FIRST AND FOREMOST,
FIRST AND FOREMOST, I NEED
EVERYBODY THAT'S WATCHING,
EVERYBODY IN THE COMMENTS, LET
US KNOW IF YOU'RE ROCKING WITH
OBJ, OR IF YOU'RE ROCKING WITH
COOPER KUPP IN THIS MATCHUP
RIGHT HERE, THESE ARE TEAMMATES
AS CONNOR MENTIONED.
CONNOR, I'M -- MAN, I STRONGLY
FEEL THE RAMS ARE LETTING ODELL
BE GREAT DURING THE PLAYOFFS.
I THINK THEY'RE JUST LETTING HIM
GO.
I THINK THAT ODELL CAN TAKE THIS
TEAM TO THE NEXT LEVEL, IF HE
GETS GOING.
I STRONGLY FEEL THAT WAY.
WE KNOW WHAT COOPER KUPP DOES.
THAT IS MATT STAFFORD'S SAFETY
BLANKET, BUT IF ODELL GETS
GOING, THIS RAMS TEAM, LOOK OUT
FOR THEM, LOOK OUT FOR THIS RAMS
TEAM.
SO WITH THAT BEING SAID, CONNOR,
WITH THAT BEING SAID, I'M NOT
GOING TO LIE, BRO, I WILL
SPRINKLE SOME MONEY ON ODELL
BECKHAM JR., I WILL SPRINKLE
SOME MONEY ON HIM TO SCORE IN
THIS MATCHUP.
PLUS 160.
WE SAW WHAT HE DID LAST WEEK.
I WOULD SPRINKLE MONEY.
IT'S PLUS 160 NOW, CONNOR, WE'RE
JUST GOING TO TAKE IT UP,
BROTHER, BUT TALK TO ME, TALK TO
THE PEOPLE, WHICH WAY ARE YOU
LEANING?
ARE YOU GOING THE SAFETY ROUTE
OR ARE YOU TAKING CHANCES?
>> MAN, I LIKE THEM BOTH,
HONESTLY.
WHEN YOU LOOK AT WHAT TODD BOSE
IS GOING TO TRY TO DO TO GAME
PLAN AGAINST THESE RAMS YOU'VE
GOT TO TAKE AWAY COOPER KUPP AND
THAT'S GOING TO LEAVE THE
MATCHUPS FOR ODELL BECKHAM WHO
IS SHOWN LATELY HE'S UP FOR THE
CHALLENGE.
AND, LISTEN, COOPER KUPP IS THE
RELIABLE GUY.
DOESN'T MATTER IF TEAMS TRY TO
ERASE HIM.
DOESN'T MEAN YOU'RE WRITING OFF
COOPER KUPP BUT WHEN YOU'RE
PLAYING THE ODDS GAME, AND WHAT
THIS RAMS TEAM HAS TO DO TO PULL
OFF AN UPSET.
THEY'VE GOT TO FEED OTHER GUYS.
THEY NEED CAM AKERS TO BE GREAT
AND ODELL BECKHAM.
IF THE BUCS ARE GOING TO
DEDICATE SO MUCH COVERAGE UP
FRONT AND THE BACK BRACT, COOPER
KUPP.
IF PEOPLE WANT TO LEAN ODELL
BECKHAM HERE, I HAVE NO PROBLEM
WITH THAT.
WHICH WAY ARE THEY LEANING?
>> LET ME FIND OUT, CONNOR, LET
ME JUMP INTO THE HANDY DANDY
iPAD AND FIND OUT.
I GOT LITTLE SAINT A 14 SAYS
PICK ME AND THE TANK WITH A
COOPER KUPP GIFT.
SHOUT OUT TO YOU LITTLE SAINT A
14, YOU ARE WALKING AWAY WITH A
HOODIE.
I ALSO HAVE -- I ALSO HAVE C THE
MAN 14 SAYS COOPER, WITH SOME
FIRE EMOJIS, HE'S ROCKING WITH
COOPER KUPP.
SHOUTOUT TO YOU, YOU ARE WALKING
AWAY WITH THE HOODIE.
CONNOR, BE OUR BET IN THIS
COMMENTS, SQUAD RIDE FOR THE
TROOPS, THAT'S WHAT THEY ARE
SAYING.
MAXLE REXLE IS IN THE COMMENTS
TALKING ABOUT COOPER KUPP.
THEREFORE, WE'RE RIDING WITH
COOPER KUPP MOVING ON TO THE
NEXT ROUND.
EVERYBODY THAT I MEPGSED,
EVERYBODY THAT I MENTIONED, YOU
ALL ARE WALKING AWAY WITH
HOODIES.
BUT CONNOR, COOPER KUPP IS
MOVING ON TO THE NEXT ROUND.
>> COOPER KUPP.
TWO FOR TWO.
HE MAKES IT THREE FOR THREE,
IT'S A SQUAD RIDE LEADER, THE
TANK LEGEND WOULD BE THE SQUAD
RIDE LEGEND.
AND IT'S GOING TO TAKE A BIG
TIME CONTENDER TO KNOCK HIM OFF
IN ROUND THREE.
SO LET'S TAKE A LOOK, FROM BIG
MIKE BOY TO SEE IF HE'S GOT THE
CONTENDER THAT CAN GET THE JOB
DONE.
>> HEY THERE, GREG AND CONNOR,
WHAT I HAVE A LOCK IN THE SAFE
IS THE ANYTIME TD LOCK FOR THIS
PLAYOFF WEEKEND.
GO AHEAD AND CHECK IT OUT.
DAVANTE ADAMS, ANYTIME TD, LOCK
HIM IN.
>> BIG TIME CONTENDER IT IS, DA
VAN DAY ADAMS, MINUS 135, TELLS
YOU WHAT VEGAS THINKS ABOUT BOTH
OF THESE GUYS AND THEIR CHANCES
OF GETTING IN THE END ZONE.
YOU KNOW WHAT, GREG, THIS IS
GOING TO BE ENOUGH FOR ME RIGHT
HERE, I WILL GET OFF THE COOPER
KUPP TRAIN FOR THE DAVANTE ADAMS
TRAIN.
I AM A LAST SECOND TRADER IN
THIS SPOT.
I LOVE THE PICK, DAVANTE ADAMS
IF WE CAN GET THAT ONE BOOSTED,
LET'S TAKE IT HOME.
ARE YOU WITH ME?
I KNOW IT'S AGAINST YOUR 9ers,
BUT YOU'RE ALSO HAVE SMART MAN,
A BALANCED MAN WHEN IT COMES TO
GAMBLING.
DO YOU LIKE DAVANTE ADAMS TO
SCORE THIS WEEK?
>> I WOULD LIKE TO THINK I'M A
SMART MAN WHEN IT COMES TO
GAMBLING.
THE AUDIENCE MIGHT THINK
SOMETHING DIFFERENT.
BUT, CONNOR, I WAS AT THAT WEEK
THREE MATCHUP, 49ers TAKING ON
THE PACKERS.
IT WAS A CLOSE GAME, CAME DOWN
TO THE LAST SECONDS, IN FACT,
CROSBY KICKED A FIELD GOAL AND
WON THE GAME.
BUT THERE WAS ONE THING THAT WAS
CONSTANT THROUGHOUT THAT GAME,
AND THAT WAS DAVANTE ADAMS
TORCHING THE 49ers CORNER BACKS.
IT WAS LIKE EVERY PLAY YOU SAW
AARON RODGERS LITERALLY STARING
DOWN MY GUY DAVANTE ADAMS AND
STILL COMPLETING THE BALL TO
HIM.
I THINK THAT CONTINUES TODAY.
I CAN SEE MY GUY DAVANTE ADAMS
SCORING A TOUCHDOWN TODAY.
SO, CONNOR, YOU MIGHT HAVE GOT
ME, BRO, YOU MIGHT HAVE GOT ME
TO SWAY ON THE OTHER SIDE.
HONESTLY, I LIKE BOTH OF THESE
PICKS.
I'LL SPRINKLE MONEY ON BOTH OF
THESE PICKS.
BUT I'M GOING TO GO TO THE
COMMENTS RIGHT NOW.
BECAUSE I WANT TO SEE WHAT
THEY'RE TALKING ABOUT.
SO WE CAN CHOOSE WHO WE ARE
RIDING TOGETHER AS A FAMILY.
LIKE I SAID, I LIKE BOTH PICKS
BUT I'M IN THE HANDY DANDY iPAD
RIGHT NOW LOOKING FOR TAKES AND
I SEE -- I SEE WATTAGES WHO SAYS
GREG HATES IT BUT YOU'VE GOT TO
GO ADAMS, BROTHER, I DO NOT HATE
IT.
I DO NOT HATE IT.
I AM A REALIST.
I KNOW WHAT THE PACKERS ARE
GOING TO TRY TO DO TODAY AGAINST
MY 49ers BUT WATTAGES, YOU ARE
WALKING AWAY WITH A HOODIE ALSO.
ALSO, MY BOY RIDDER WAS IN THE
COMMENTS, MIKE RIDDER, HE
MENTIONED TE WAS FROM THE BAY,
DAVANTE ADAMS IS FROM THE BAY,
OR CLOSE TO IT.
SHOUTOUT TO YOU RIDDER, I GOT
ONE MORE, ONE MORE IN ME.
ONE MORE IN ME.
I GOT D BOY 22, D BOY 22 SAYS
ADAMS IS GOING TO GET TWO
TOUCHDOWNS, LET'S GO, CONNOR.
I THINK THE PEOPLE HAVE SPOKEN.
THE COMMENTS IS ALL DAVANTE
ADAMS, COOPER KUPP IS NOWHERE TO
BE MENTIONED.
SO THEREFORE, WE, EVERYBODY, ARE
RIDING DAVANTE ADAMS TO SCORE A
TOUCHDOWN, TO SCORE A TOUCHDOWN
TODAY.
LET'S PULL UP THE ODDS.
LET'S PULL UP THE ODDS SO I CAN
SHOW YOU WHAT WE ARE GOING TO DO
TODAY ON THE SQUAD RIDE.
IT'S MINUS 135, LET'S SEE THE
MAGIC GUYS IN THE CONTROL ROOM.
THERE IT IS.
PLUS 100 NOW.
GO GET IT.
CONNOR.
WE DID IT, BRO, WE CHANGED IT
FROM MINUS 135 TO PLUS 100.
LET ME GIVE OUT A JERSEY, AND
LET ME GIVE OUT 250 DK DOLLARS
RIGHT NOW.
I'M BACK INTO THE COMMENTS,
CONNOR.
I AM BACK INTO THE COMMENTS.
>> LET'S DO IT.
>> ROB DOG 22 SAYS DAVANTE THE
MAN ADAMS, TWO TOUCHDOWNS TODAY,
BABY, SHOUTOUT TO YOU, ROB DOG
22, YOU ARE WALKING AWAY WITH
250 DK DOLLARS FOR YOUR TAKE.
I LOVE YOUR GIFT, TOO, SO
SHOUTOUT TO YOU AND I'M ALSO
GIVING AWAY A JERSEY.
I GOT ONE MORE JERSEY.
IT'S ACTUALLY LOFTBERG.
LOFTBERG, DAVANTE ADAMS IS ON
FIRE, GO PAT GO.
SHOUTOUT TO YOU LOFTBERG, YOU
ARE WALKING AWAY WITH A JERSEY.
CONNOR, LET'S GET TO SEGMENT
TWO, BRO.
LET'S GO.
>> WE HAD A LOT OF FUN WITH THE
TOUCHDOWN SCORES, DAVANTE ADAMS
BOOSTED UP TO PLUS 100.
YOU KNOW WHAT TO DO WHEN THE
SHOW IS OVER.
DON'T WASTE ANY TIME AND KEEP
THE COMMENTS JUMPING.
WE'VE GOT A LOT TO GIVE AWAY.
SPEAKING OF THAT, GREG, WE'VE
GOT A LOT OF THESE MATCH YAWPS
TO GO THROUGH.
THIS IS JUST A PHENOMENAL SLATE
OF GAMES, AND WE'RE GOING TO
GIVE ALL OF OUR FAVORITE MAJOR
MARKET BETS OF THE WEEK.
LAST WEEK WE WERE TALKING MONEY
LINES AND WE'RE NOT AFRAID TO
GET IN ON THAT ACTION AGAIN BUT
INSTEAD THIS WEEK WE'RE GOING TO
GO BEST BETS FROM EACH MATCHUP.
BUT FIRST, NEED YOU TO DO
SOMETHING.
YOU'VE GOT TO GET ON DRAFTKINGS.
YOU'VE GOT TO GET ON DRAFTKINGS
BECAUSE THE FIRST TIME CUSTOMERS
CAN PLACE A MONEY LIVE BET OF $5
OR MORE DURING THE POSTSEASON,
AND IF YOUR BET WINS YOU'LL
RECEIVE $280 IN FREE BETS, IN
ADDITION TO YOUR CASH WINNINGS.
I THINK YOU LIKE THE SOUND OF
THAT, GREG?
>> YES, SIR, CONNOR, I LOVE THE
SOUND OF THAT, AND CONNOR AND I
ARE GOING GAME BY GAME, AND
GIVING YOU OUR FAVORITE MAJOR
MARKET PICKS.
GET IN THE COMMENTS AND TELL US
WHAT YOU THINK ABOUT OUR PICKS.
I'M GIVING AWAY HOODIES, I'M
GIVING AWAY JERSEYS AND I'M ALSO
GIVING AWAY ANOTHER, CONNOR,
ANOTHER 250 DK DOLLARS, BRO, I
LOVE GIVING AWAY THOSE 250 DK
DOLLARS, BRO, THAT'S A PARLAY,
THAT'S A PARLAY, 250 DOWN ON THE
PARLAY, YOU'RE BUMPING.
>> THAT'S A BIG TIME PARLAY.
AND SPEAKING OF THOSE PARLAYS,
HERE WE MIGHT TAKE SOME OF THESE
BEST BET PICKS, PUT THEM
TOGETHER FOR ONE AT THE END OF
THIS.
STICK AROUND, FIRST UP, WE'VE
GOT THE BENGALS GOING TO
NASHVILLE, TENNESSEE.
BECAUSE THE TITANS ARE THE
NUMBER ONE SEED IN THE AFC,
MAYBE THE MOST HATED ON NUMBER
ONE SEED OF ALL TIME.
SO THE BENGALS, 3 1/2 POINTS
SEPARATE THESE TEAMS RIGHT NOW.
YOU SEE THE POINT TOTAL, A VERY
AVERAGE 47 1/2.
MAN, GREG, I'M LOOKING AT THIS
GAME, IT'S ONE OF THE HARDER
ONES TO PREDICT.
I LIKE THE BENGALS SPREAD A LOT.
BUT MY BEST BET I'M GOING TO
TAKE THAT POINT TOTAL UP JUST A
LITTLE BIT TO 51 1/2, AND GO
UNDER.
I KNOW EVERYBODY'S ON JOE BURROW
SLICING AND DICING THIS TITANS
SECONDARY, EVERYBODY'S JACKED UP
THAT DERRICK HENRY IS BACK BUT I
LOOK AT THIS ONE, AND THAT, TO
ME, JUST MEANS MORE RUN GAME, I
THINK THEY ARE GOING TO LEAN ON
MIXON FOR THE BENGALS.
I LIKE CHANGING THE POINT TOTAL
AND GOING UNDER.
WHERE ARE YOU GOING WITH THE
FIRST GAME OF DIVISIONAL
WEEKEND?
>> I SEE WHAT YOU'RE DOING,
CONNOR, I'M RIGHT HERE WITH YOU.
I SEE WHAT YOU'RE DOING, YOU
KNOW, TAKING IT UP AND THEN
GOING UNDER.
I SEE WHAT YOU'RE DOING.
BUT CONNOR, I'M GOING TO PICK A
SIDE HERE.
I'M NOT GOING TO GO OVER-UNDER,
I'M GOING TO PICK A SIDE, AND
I'M GOING MONEY LINE.
NO SPREAD, MONEY LINE.
I'M GOING WITH THE BENGALS.
HOT PICK, PEOPLE HAVE BEEN
TALKING ABOUT IT ALL MY LIFE.
THE BENGALS AGAINST THE TITANS,
YOU SAY ONE OF THE MOST HATED ON
ONE SEEDS EVER, PROBABLY.
SO I'M HATING ON THEM.
NO HALT HATE, NO HATE.
BUT I'M ROCKING WITH THE
BENGALS, CONNOR, AND WITH THAT
MONEY LINE.
THAT PLUS 155 IS JUST LOOKING
TOO TEMPTING NEAR.
>> ALL RIGHT, GREG, WHERE ARE
THE COMMENTS GOING RIGHT NOW?
I FEEL LIKE SO MUCH OF THE
PUBLIC DOES LIKE THE BENGALS, IS
LAUGHING AT THE TITANS.
WE'RE GOING TO SEE HOW THAT
SHAKES OUT, AND OBVIOUSLY THE
BENGALS ARE A HOT TEAM RIGHT
NOW.
HOW ARE THE COMMENTS FEELING
ABOUT THIS MATCHUP?
>> CONNOR, I GOT RICHY 21 IN THE
COMMENTS SAYING TITANS HENRY IS
COMING TO EAT TODAY.
THEY THINK HENRY IS GOING TO BE
EATING.
LOVEBURN IS BACK, HE SAYS IT'S A
GREAT DAY TO BET FOOTBALL.
SHOUTOUT TO YOU.
>> THAT'S RIGHT.
>> BE OUR BETTING IS IN THE
COMMENTS, PLUS MONEY, GREG.
YEAH, I'M -- I'M A PICKLE.
I'M A PICKLE SENIOR BENGALS GOT
IT, EVERYBODY THAT I MENTIONED,
EVEN BE OUR BETTING, YOU ARE ALL
GETTING AWAY WITH THE HOODIE.
CONNOR, LET'S GET TO THIS NEXT
MATCHUP.
LET'S GET TO IT.
>> LET'S DO IT.
BECAUSE IT'S YOUR 9ers, GOING TO
THE TUNDRA, IN LAMBO FIELD, THE
MOST EXCITING MATCHUP.
TWO OLD SCHOOL FRANCHISES.
FIVE POINTS SEPARATES THEM.
KEEP IN MIND HOW COLD IT IS
THERE.
AND, YOU KNOW, YOUR 9ers GETTING
SOME PLUS MONEY THERE, GREG.
BUT I'M LOOKING AT THIS GAME AND
I WILL PICK A SIDE.
I'M NOT GOING TO BE BOLD ENOUGH
TO PICK THE PACKERS TO WIN BY
ALMOST A TOUCHDOWN, BUT I WILL
SAY MONEY LINE.
THAT'S BECAUSE I HAVE TO.
MY ONLY SUPER BOWL FUTURES
TICKET LEFT IS THE PACKERS.
I HAVE NO CHOICE.
I CAN'T JUMP SHIP NOW.
I APOLOGIZE, GREG.
THERE'S NO DISRESPECT.
WHERE ARE YOU GOING, THOUGH, DO
YOU BELIEVE IN YOUR 9ers TO GET
THE JOB DONE ON THE ROAD?
>> CONNOR, I'LL SAY THIS.
WEEK THREE I WAS THERE.
IN SANTA CLARA, WATCHING THE
PACKERS TAKE ON THE 49ers.
THE PACKERS CONTROLLED THE GAME
FOR MOST OF THE GAME.
NOT GOING TO LIE.
THEY CONTROLLED THE GAME.
BUT GUESS WHAT, JIMMY G. AND THE
BOYS CAME BATTLING BACK AT THE
END.
BUT AARON RODGERS HAD TOO MUCH
TIME LEFT, WENT DOWN THE FIELD.
KICKED THE FIELD GOAL.
IT WAS A CLOSE GAME.
I'M SAYING ALL THIS BECAUSE IT
WAS A CLOSE GAME.
I DON'T KNOW WHERE THE
ODDSMAKERS SEE ALMOST A
TOUCHDOWN.
I DON'T SEE -- I DON'T KNOW WHAT
THEY'RE THINKING.
BUT THEY SEE IT -- THEY SEE THIS
AS THE PALKERS WINNING BY ALMOST
A TOUCHDOWN.
I DO NOT.
I THINK THIS IS GOING TO BE A
CLOSE GAME.
THEREFORE I'M ROCKING WITH THE
49ers SPREAD, 49ers SPREAD.
AND CONNOR, I ALSO WANT TO
MENTION THIS, I MENTIONED THIS
LAST WEEK AND I'LL MENTION IT
AGAIN.
IN THE NFL, IT IS EXTREMELY HARD
TO BE THE TEAM TWICE.
AND I'LL JUST LEAVE IT AT THAT.
TAKE THE 9ers, PLUS THE POINTS
TONIGHT.
>> MAN, IS IT EVER?
IT ABSOLUTELY IS.
IT'S A GOOD POINT, GREG, THIS IS
GOING TO BE AN EXCITING GAME.
I DON'T THINK IT WILL BE A
BLOWOUT.
THEY'RE TRYING TO TELL YOU THAT
VEGAS THINKS THERE'S A CHANCE IT
WILL.
SO WE'RE GOING TO HAVE OUR EYES
ON THAT ONE.
WHICH WAY ARE THE COMMENTS
LEANING RIGHT NOW?
THE PACKERS HAVE BEEN THE SUPER
BOWL FAVORITE ON EVERY FUTURES
BOARD THAT'S STILL OUT THERE
RIGHT NOW.
YOU CAN STILL GET IN ON THE
ACTION, AND WE'LL LOOK AT THAT
LATER.
BUT THE 9ers, HUGE FAN BASE.
HOT TEAM.
KYLE SHANAHAN HAS BEEN TO THE
SUPER BOWL BEFORE, AND THIS
ISN'T JUST WITH THE 9ers.
HE DID IT WITH THE FALCONS AS
WELL.
SO THERE'S A BIG REASON TO
BELIEVE IN KYLE.
WHICH WAY ARE THE COMMENTS
LEANING IN THIS GAME?
>> YOU -- THE COMMENTS ARE
JUMPING, BANG BANG #ER GAME.
YOU SEE THE GIFT RIGHT THERE.
CITY 3184 GOT THE GEORGE KITTLE
GIFT GOING.
SHOUTOUT TO YOU, WALKING AWAY
WITH A HOODIE.
GEORGE NY 22 CG, HE SAYS DEEBO
IS STEALING GREEN BAY'S BITE
TODAY.
ROCKING WITH THE 9ers.
I GOT ONE MORE, CONNOR, AND
WE'RE GOING TO GO RIGHT HERE TO
PETER RAIDER 909, HE'S CONFUSED
BECAUSE HE'S A RAIDER FAN.
RAIDER 909, GREEN BABY TEN
POINTS THIS TIME AROUND AND HE
IS SHUSHING, I GUESS, ALL THE
9ER FANS UP, SHOUTOUT TO YOU
RAIDER 909.
YOU ARE WALKING AWAY WITH A
HOODIE.
>> ALL RIGHT.
LET'S GET TO SUNDAY --
>> YES, SIR, YES, SIR.
>> TAKE US TO SUNDAY.
RAMS GOING TO TAMPA.
THE REIGNING SUPER BOWL CHAMPS
WITH THE BUCS.
AND, MAN, RAMS LOOK PRETTY GOOD
LAST WEEK, SO THIS IS GOING TO
BE A LOT OF PEOPLE NEVER PICK
AGAINST TOM BRADY.
THIS ONE'S TIGHT.
PLUS 2 1/2 FOR THE RAMS, PLUS
MONEY THERE.
ANOTHER POINT TOTAL AROUND 47
FOR THE THIRD TIME IN A ROW.
GREG, FOR THIS ONE, I'M KEEPING
THAT PARLAY TICKET IN MIND, I
LIKE THE RAMS SPREAD, AND I LIKE
IT TO 4 1/2.
I WANT THE FIELD GOAL HERE,
GREG, SO I'M GOING TO BUY SOME
EXTRA POINTS.
NOT GOING TO CHANGE THE ODDS
THAT MUCH.
2 1/2 IS PLUS MONEY SO I'LL GET
IT TO 4 1/2 HERE.
THEY AT LEAST HANG OR NOT WITH
THE BUCS, AND MIGHT EVEN
SURPRISE THEM.
ARE YOU WITH ME ON THIS ONE?
>> CONNOR, I AM WITH YOU ON THIS
ONE.
BUT, BROTHER, BUT -- I'M NOT
BUYING NO POINTS CARD.
I'M NOT GOING TO BUY ANY POINTS.
THE PLUS 2 1/2, LOOK AT IT,
BROTHER, IT'S PLUS MONEY.
IT'S PLUS MONEY.
I HONESTLY, I THINK THE RAMS CAN
WIN THIS GAME.
SO I'M JUST GOING TO PLAY IT
SAFE.
PLUS 2 1/2, IT'S PLUS MONEY,
EVEN MONEY, GIVE IT TO ME.
I'M GOING TO TAKE THAT AND I'M
ROCKING WITH THE RAMS TO COVER
THE SPREAD AGAINST TOM BRADY AND
THOSE INJURED TAMPA BAY
BUCCANEERS.
>> ALL RIGHT, SO WE'RE ON THE
RAMS.
I WOULD IMAGINE THE PUBLIC IS
USUALLY ON THE BUCS, AND THERE
ARE A LOT OF RAMS DOUBTERS,
WHERE ARE OUR COMMENTS RIGHT
NOW?
ARE THEY BUYING THE RAMS UPSET,
OR ARE THEY ROLLING WITH OLD
RELIABLE, LITERALLY OLD RELIABLE
TOM BRADY?
>> HE SAID LITERALLY OLD
RELIABLE.
I LIKE THAT, CONNOR.
I GOT S YOUNG 37 SAYS, OH,
SHUCKS, IT'S THE BUCS.
I DON'T REALLY KNOW WHAT HE
MEANS BY THAT, BUT YOU ARE
WALKING AWAY WITH THE HOODIE FOR
YOUR TAKE.
THE RAIDER FAN 4209 HAS THE
RAM -- YOU SEE, YOU GUYS SEE THE
GIF RIGHT THERE, I DON'T HAVE TO
EXPLAIN IT.
RAIDER FAN, THERE'S THE USER
NAME RIGHT THERE AS YOU GUYS CAN
SEE.
HOLD ON, LET ME GET IT IN YOU
GUYS' FRAME.
RAIDER FAN 4209, YOU ARE ALSO
WALKING AWAY WITH A HOODIE.
I GOT ONE MORE IN ME, CONNOR,
ONE MORE IN ME, MASTER JEDI
RIGHT HERE, THE O LINE IS HURT
FOR TAMPA BAY, DEFENSIVE LINE
FOR L.A. IS ONE OF THE BEST, USE
THE FORCE, TAKE THE RAMS AND THE
POINTS, BROTHER, WE ARE TAKING
THE RAMS, AND THE POINTS.
SO SHOUTOUT TO EVERYBODY THAT I
JUST MENTIONED.
YOU ALL HAVE WALKING AWAY WITH
HOODIES.
CONNOR, WE GOT ONE MORE GAME
LEFT, RIGHT?
>> ONE MORE GAME, AND IT IS
PROJECTED AS THE TIGHTEST
MATCHUP OF THEM ALL.
WITH THE BILLS GOING TO KANSAS
CITY, AND WHEN YOU LOOK AT THAT
ONE, IT IS ONLY A POINT AND A
HALF DIFFERENCE RIGHT NOW.
NOW WE'VE GONE 47-47-47 FOR THE
POINT TOTALS.
WE ARE GOING TO JACK THAT UP BY
A TOUCHDOWN, ALL THE WAY UP TO
54.
SO THEY ARE EXPECTING SHOOTOUT
CITY WITH JOSH ALLEN AND PATRICK
MAHOMES.
I MEAN, UNDISPUTED.
THE TOP TWO QUARTERBACKS IN THE
AFC RIGHT NOW, IN THIS GAME.
THIS IS GOING TO BE A THRILLER.
THEY'RE SAVING IT FOR SUNDAY
EVENING.
BUILDING THAT EXCITEMENT.
AND GREG, FOR ME, IT'S ABOUT THE
POINTS IN THIS ONE.
KEEPING THE PARLAY IN MIND, I'M
GOING TO GO DOWN TO ABOUT 50.5
POINTS HERE, AND SAY THAT
SMASHES OVER.
I LIKE ALLEN TO THROW ON THE
CHIEFS.
BUT I KNOW ANDY REID AND PATRICK
MAHOMES WILL PUNCH BACK.
I LIKE THE POINTS TO GET A
LITTLE CRAZY IN THIS ONE.
WHERE ARE YOU THINKING FOR
BILLS/CHIEFS?
>> I'M RIGHT THERE WITH YOU,
CONNOR, I'M GOING OVER HERE.
I THINK THIS ONE'S GOING TO BE A
SHOOTOUT.
WE'VE GOT TWO REALLY GOOD
OFFENSES, AND THEN WE HAVE A
SORT OF AILING DEFENSE WITH THE
CHIEFS.
SO I SEE A LOT OF OFFENSE.
I SEE A LOT OF FIREWORKS, AND I
SEE A LOT OF POINTS BEING
SCORED.
I'M ROCKING WITH THE OVER HERE,
BROTHER, I AM ROCKING WITH THE
OVER, AND I CAN'T WAIT TO WATCH
THIS ONE TOMORROW.
>> ALL RIGHT, TIGHTEST MATCHUP
OF THE WEEKEND, WHAT ARE THE
PEOPLE THINKING FOR THIS ONE?
THEY ROLLING WITH JOSH ALLEN, ON
THE HYPE TRAIN FOR JOSH ALLEN TO
REIGN SUPREME, OR ARE THEY
STICKING WITH PATRICK MAHOMES?
>> I GOT STEVE CITY, OH,
ACTUALLY CITY 3184, YOU SEE THE
STEFON DIGGS GIF RIGHT THERE, HE
ALSO DROPPED THIS GIF RIGHT HERE
OF THE BUFFALO, RIGHT THERE, SO
SHOUTOUT TO YOU CITY 3184,
WALKING AWAY WITH A HOODIE.
AND C BIG B, BILLS NOT STOPPING
IN KANSAS CITY, L.A. BOUND FOR
SURE, SHOUTOUT TO UC BIG B,
YOU'RE WALKING AWAY WITH A
HOODIE.
ONE MORE, YOU GUYS SEE LOGAN
DOWN THERE, LOGAN L 3 IGGZ SAYS
CHIEFS, SO SHOUTOUT TO YOU,
LOGAN, YOU ARE ALSO ROCKING AWAY
WITH A HOODIE, EVERYBODY THAT I
MENTIONED, YOU ALL ARE WALKING
AWAY WITH A BE OUR BETTING
HOODIE.
>> LET'S MAKE THINGS
INTERESTING, YOU'VE HEARD ALL
OUR PICKS, LET'S MATCH THEM ALL
TOGETHER IN ONE BIG PARLAY OVER
HERE FROM EVERY BIG TIME GAME
THIS WEEK, AND GREG, LET THEM
KNOW WHAT WE NEED, THE PEOPLE TO
DO RIGHT NOW TO GET IN ON THE
ACTION OF ALL THESE GIVEAWAYS?
>> I NEED EVERYBODY TO GET IN
THE COMMENTS AND TELL US IF YOU
ARE RIDING WITH ME OR MY MAN
CONNOR.
IF YOU GUYS ARE RIDING WITH
EITHER OF US, AND I'M GIVING
AWAY HOODIES AND I'M GIVING AWAY
JERSEYS AND I'M ALSO AT 250
PARLAY BK DOLLARS, I'M GIVING
AWAY THAT AS WELL, CONNOR.
>> YEAH, IT'S A PRETTY SWEET
DEAL.
LET'S TAKE A LOOK AT THESE
PARLAYS RIGHT NOW, TO SHOW THE
PEOPLE A LITTLE REMINDER TO THE
PEOPLE WHAT WE'RE WORKING WITH
HERE, ALL RIGHT, HERE'S MINE
FIRST, ONLY COMING IN AT PLUS
433, PLAYING IT, I GUESS, AS YOU
COULD SAY FOR PLUS 433.
WE'RE LOOKING UNDER, BOUGHT UP
FOR BENGALS TITANS, PACKERS TO
WIN OUTRIGHT.
RAMS TO COVER, SHOOTOUT OF THE
WEEKEND, BILLS CHIEFS, GOT TO
GET OVER 50.
LET'S TAKE A LOOK AT GREG'S
RIGHT NOW.
HE CAME IN BOLD ON THIS ONE,
BOLD AND READY TO GO, MAN, GREG,
I LIKE WHAT YOU GOT COOKING UP
HERE, REMIND THE PEOPLE WHAT YOU
GOT.
>> YES, SIR, CONNOR, YOU ALREADY
KNOW, WE'RE ROCKING WITH THE
BANG BANG 9ers GANG, ROCKING
WITH THE SPREAD WITH THE 9ers
AND WE GOT BENGALS MONEY LINE
HERE, CONNOR AND THEN HERE IN
THIS ONE A LOT.
LIKE I MENTIONED PEOPLE IN MY
DMs, WINNERS ONLY SHOW, THEY'RE
TALKING ABOUT THE BENGALS, AND I
AM RIDING, SO I'M TAKING MONEY
LINE, NOT THE POINTS, MONEY LINE
WITH THE BENGALS, RAMS, PLUS
2.5.
THIS IS PLUS MONEY, CONNOR.
RAMS SPREAD IS PLUS MONEY, I'M
TAKING THAT AS WELL.
ALSO, I THINK THAT THERE'S GOING
TO BE A SHOOTOUT THAT KANSAS
CITY BUFFALO BILLS GAME I THINK
THIS IS -- I JUST THINK A LOT OF
POINTS ARE GOING TO BE SCORED IN
THAT ONE.
SO, YEAH, YOU ROUND ALL THAT UP.
IT'S PLUS 1758.
GET RICH.
>> I THINK THIS QUALIFIES AS
YOUR BOLDEST BET AS WELL, GREG,
I THINK THAT'S PRETTY FAIR TO
SAY.
NOW, I KNOW YOU'VE GOT AN NFL
JERSEY.
THE 250 DK DOLLARS.
WHAT ARE THE PEOPLE JUMPING OFF
RIGHT NOW?
WHAT ARE THEY ON, WHAT ARE THEY
BUYING?
WHAT ARE THEY SELLING RIGHT NOW?
LET THEM KNOW?
>> GARRETT BEAM IN THE COMMENTS,
SAYS DON'T SLEEP OVER TOTAL IN
JOSH ALLEN FIRST TD SCORE, THERE
IT IS RIGHT THERE, I LOVE THE
TAKE.
I LOVE THE TEDDY BEAR FOUR.
GARRETT, CONGRATULATIONS, YOU
ARE WALKING AWAY WITH 250 DK
DOLLARS, AND I HOPE, I HOPE, I
HOPE YOU GO PARLAY THAT.
I HOPE YOU DO.
SO SHOUTOUT TO YOU, GARRETT.
I ALSO -- I'M ALSO GIVING AWAY A
JERSEY, RIGHT, CONNOR?
>> OH, YEAH, YOU GOT ONE MORE
JERSEY, AND YOU GOT PLENTY MORE
AFTER THIS, BUT FOR THIS, ONE
JERSEY.
>> HERE WE GO, WE GOT HTWO, HE
SAYS RIDING WITH GREG, NO SCARED
MONEY ON THE RAMS, EVEN RIDING
WITH THE BENGALS AND 9ers,
ALL -- EVEN -- I'M SORRY, I'M
SORRY, GUYS, I GRADUATED
COLLEGE, AND I PROMISE THAT.
LET ME TAKE ANOTHER STAB AT
THIS.
RIDING WITH GREG, NO SCARE MONEY
ON THE RAMS, EVEN RIDING WITH
THE BENGALS AND 9ers, RIDING ALL
THE WAY, I THINK GREG HITS
LOCKED.
THERE IT IS, CONNOR, THAT'S WHAT
MY GUY HTWO SAID, AND HTWO, YOU
ARE WALKING AWAY WITH THE
JERSEY.
YOUR CHOICE.
>> ALL RIGHT, SHOUTOUT TO THE
COMMENTERS, AND DON'T FORGET,
GET ON DRAFTKINGS, TAKE
ADVANTAGE OF THAT $5 TO WIN
$280.
THE DEAL I READ AT THE TOP OF
THE SHOW WHEN YOU LOCK YOUR
MONEY LINE BETS THIS WEEKEND.
PRETTY SWEET.
ALL RIGHT.
FOR THE REGS, FOR THE LOYAL
VIEWERS, YOU KNOW WHAT TIMES
THE, IT'S TIME FOR PROP, LOCK OR
DROP IT, AND IN HONOR OF
DIVISIONAL WEEKEND, OUR FRIENDS
OVER AT DRAFTKINGS ARE OFFERING
A SAME GAME PARLAY SPECIAL.
WE'RE GOING TO GET IN ON THAT
PARLAY AS WELL.
GREG, LET THEM KNOW WHAT WE GOT
GOING ON.
>> CONNOR, EVERYBODY AT HOME,
PLACE A MINIMUM OF $10 BET ON
ANY DIVISIONAL ROUND GAME TODAY
AND TOMORROW, AND RE-SEE A FREE
BET.
>> THAT'S PRETTY GOOD TO ME.
ALL RIGHT, GREG, WE LOVE A GOOD
PARLAY AROUND HERE.
SO I THINK IT'S TIME, AS WE
TEASED AT THE TOP.
TO MAKE THINGS A LITTLE BIT
INTERESTING WITH THE PLAYER
PROPS THIS WEEKEND.
BLEND THEM ALL INTO A SAME-GAME
PARLAY.
WHAT DO WE GOT FIRST UP HERE?
>> WELL, FIRST AND FOREMOST,
CONNOR, FIRST AND FOREMOST, I
NEED EVERYBODY THAT'S WATCHING
TO GET IN THE COMMENTS AND TELL
US WHETHER TO LOCK OR DROP THESE
PROPS, LET'S GET TO THE FIRST
ONE, CONNOR, LET'S GET TO THE
FIRST ONE.
AARON RODGERS, OVER OR UNDER?
AARON RODGERS, OVER OR UNDER,
254 1/2 YARDS.
CONNOR, ARE YOU LOCKING THIS ONE
OR DROPPING THIS ONE?
>> I'M LOCKING THE OVER HERE,
FOR AARON RODGERS.
I THINK HE COMES OUT FIRING.
I THINK HE COMES OUT READY TO GO
AGAINST THAT 9ers SECONDARY.
I THINK YOU'RE GOING TO SEE A
BIG DAY, NOT SURPRISINGLY, FOR
DAVANTE ADAMS.
BUT MOST IMPORTANTLY A BIG DAY
THROUGH THE AIR.
THIS ISN'T A SCARY NUMBER.
THERE'S NO REASON TO FEAR IT.
I KNOW THEY'RE GOING TO WANT TO
RUN THE BALL.
THEY'VE GOT A LOT OF TOP
DEFENDERS BACK, THEY'LL PLAY
GOOD DEFENSE BUT AARON IS AARON,
HE'S GOING TO COME OUT RIPPING
THAT THING.
GREG, ARE YOU ROLL BEING ME
HERE?
ARE WE GOING TO KEEP THIS ONE
MOVING?
>> I MEAN -- I MENTIONED -- I'LL
TALK ABOUT THIS.
I MENTIONED THAT I'VE SAW WITH
MY OWN EYES WHAT AARON RODGERS
DID TO THAT 49ers SECONDARY,
CONNOR, AND I THINK THAT HE
POSSIBLY HAS A CHANCE AT DOING
IT AGAIN.
DON'T MEAN HE'S GOING TO WIN THE
GAME, BUT I THINK THAT HE CAN
GET HIS TODAY BY JUST SIMPLY
THROWING THE BALL TO DAVANTE
ADAMS.
I'M GOING TO ROCK WITH THE OVER.
>> YEAH, IF IT'S A CLOSE GAME,
HE'S JUST GOING TO BE THROWING
THE BALL MORE TO TRY TO GET THAT
WIN.
SO ACROSS FROM HIM IS YOUR BOY
JIMMY G, LOOKING AT HIS
OVER/UNDER THIS WEEK.
NOT THAT DIFFERENT.
244.5.
ONLY TEN YARDS LESS THAN
RODGERS, AND FOR PEOPLE AT HOME
THINKING THAT'S ABSOLUTELY
CRAZY, JIMMY'S THROWN FOR OVER
300 IN TWO OF HIS LAST THREE
GAMES.
SO JIMMY CAN RACK UP THE YARD
TOTALS.
IT HELPS WHEN YOU HAVE DEEBO
SAMUEL OUT THERE TO CHUCK IT TO
AND LET HIM ROUN AROUND THE
FIELD.
THOSE COUNT IN THE BOX SCORE.
THEY COUNT FOR THE BETS.
I'M STILL AFRAID OF THIS ONE FOR
JIM
JIMMY G BECAUSE HE'S BANGED UP,
IT'S THE PACKERS, THEY GOT A LOT
OF BIG DOGS BACK ON THEIR
DEFENSE.
I'M GOING TO GO UNDER HERE,
GREG, WHERE ARE YOU GOING?
>> I'M RIGHT THERE WITH YOU,
CONNOR.
I'M A 9ER FAN, EVERYBODY HERE
KNOWS.
BUT I'M -- IT'S HARD FOR ME TO
PUT MY MONEY ON JIMMY G, CONNOR,
I'LL BE HONEST, IT'S HARD FOR ME
TO TRUST AND PUT MY MONEY ON
JIMMY G, BUT, WITH THAT BEING
SAID, I'M ROCKING WITH THE UNDER
HERE.
I THINK THE 9ers ARE GOING TO
TRY TO CONTROL THE BALL.
THEY'RE GOING TO TRY TO CONTROL
THE TIME OF POSSESSION.
THEY'RE GOING TO TRY TO RUN THE
BALL WE LIELI MITCHELL.
THEY'RE GOING TO TRY TO KEEP THE
BALL OUT OF AARON ROD GER''S
HANDS.
HE WILL NOT GO OVER HIS PASSING
YARDS TOTAL.
I'M GOING WITH THE UNDER.
>> LOOKING AT THE RECEIVERS AND
THE RECEIVING YARDS TOTAL, WE'RE
GOING TO START WITH THE STAR OF
THE SHOW, SO FAR, AND THAT'S
DAVANTE ADAMS, ONLY 89 1/2.
SO GOT TO GET TO THAT 90 MARKER,
AND USUALLY I CALL THESE SUCKER
BETS OR TRAPS.
BECAUSE THEY ARE SET HIGH.
AND IT'S WITH A STAR.
BUT HE'S TOO GOOD.
HE'S TOO GOOD, DAVANTE ADAMS,
AND THIS IS AARON RODGERS' GUY,
THE 9ers SECONDARY HAS THEIR
QUESTION MARKS, I'M GOING TO GO
THE OVER HERE, I THINK DAVANTE
CAN EASILY BE IN FOR THAT 100
YARD KIND OF DAY, GREG.
>> YEAH, EVERYBODY STOP WHAT
YOU'RE DOING.
GO ON YOUR LOCAL BETTING SITE,
AND GO BET THIS BET RIGHT NOW.
GO BET THIS BET RIGHT NOW,
BECAUSE I CAN SEE MY GUY,
DAVANTE ADAMS, GOING OVER THIS
EASILY, I SEEN IT WITH MY OWN
EYES, I'M TELLING YOU GUYS I
SEEN IT MY OWN EYES, WEEK THREE
AGAINST THE 49ers, THE CHEMISTRY
AGAINST AARON RODGERS AND
DAVANTE ADAMS WAS LIKE NO OTHER.
IT DIDN'T MATTER WHAT THE 9ers
DID, THEY CANNOT STOP DAVANTE
ADAMS.
THAT MIGHT HAPPEN TODAY.
I HOPE IT DOESN'T.
IT MIGHT HAPPEN TODAY.
I'M PUTTING MY MONEY ON THIS,
CONNOR, I FEEL PRETTY CONFIDENT
ABOUT IT.
>> A WELL BALANCED FAN, ALL
RIGHT, THE LAST PROP CHECK HERE
FOR THE PARLAY TICKET, GOT TO
BRING IT BACK TO THE 9ers.
WE'RE GOING WITH GEORGE KITTLE.
SET AT 59 1/2.
HE HAS NOT COME CLOSE TO THIS
THE LAST COUPLE OF GAMES.
HE'S NOT BEEN A FOCAL POINT OF
THE PASSING ATTACK.
HE HAS BEEN DOMINATING AS A
BLOCKER.
THAT'S HOW GOOD KITTLE IS.
HE CAN DO JUST ABOUT EVERYTHING
AT THE POSITION.
NOW, THAT COULD MEAN THAT HE'S
DUE, GREG, AND HE GOES FOR 80,
90, BUT I'M GOING TO GO WITH
WHAT WE'VE SEEN FOR A WHILE.
THE 9ers LIKE THE BLOCKING
ASPECT OF KITTLE.
ESTABLISHING THE RUN GAME.
I CAN SEE HIM POPPING OUT OF 40
OR 45 OR 50, THE NUMBER IS TOO
HIGH FOR ME, GREG, UNDER.
>> I'M RIGHT THERE WITH YOU,
CONNOR, I AM RIGHT THERE WITH
YOU.
WHICH GEORGE KITTLE ARE WE
GETTING TODAY, THE RUN BLOCK
GEORGE KITTLE OR ARE WE GETTING
THE RECEIVING GEORGE KITTLE?
THE ALL PRO TIGHT END, RECEIVING
GEORGE KITTLE?
LIKE HE'S AN ALL PRO.
HE'S AN ALL PRO.
EVEN BLOCKING HE'S AN ALL PRO.
BUT WE JUST DON'T KNOW WHICH
GEORGE KITTLE ARE WE GETTING AND
PUTTING MY MONEY ON IT, I'M JUST
KIND OF SKEPTICAL ABOUT THAT.
I MENTIONED WITH THE 49ers
SHOULD DO IN THIS MATCHUP.
NOT TO GIVE THE BALL TO ELI
MITCHELL.
FIND DEEBO A COUPLE OF TIMES,
CONTROL THE TIME OF POSSESSION.
SO I'M GOING TO ROCK WITH THE
UNDER HERE AS WELL AS WITH YOU,
CONNOR, I'M GOING TO ROCK WITH
THE UNDER IN MY GUY GEORGE
KITTLE GOING OVER THAT RECEIVING
TOTAL.
>> SO GREG AND I SAW EYE TOI EY
ON ALL FOUR PROPS WHICH MEANS WE
HAVE A PRETTY JUICY PARLAY
TICKET WE'RE READY TO SHOW YOU
AND WHILE WE GET TO THAT, GREG,
AS THE SEGMENT CLOSES, AN NFL
JERSEY, HOODIES, AND, YOU KNOW
THE DEAL, 250 DK DOLLARS.
SO GET ON IN THERE, GIVE IT ALL
AWAY.
>> HERE IT IS, THERE IS WHERE IT
HAPPENS RIGHT HERE, CONNOR, I
GOT BAD SPORTS TAKES, SAYS
KITTLE IS GOING LITTLE.
HE'S GOING UNDER.
YOU GUYS SEE IT RIGHT THERE.
YOU GUYS SEE IT.
SHOUTOUT TO YOU, BROTHER, YOU
ARE WALKING AWAY WITH A JERSEY
FOR THAT SPORTS TAKE.
AND YOU GUYS SAW THE COMMENTS
JUMP.
I LIKE THIS ONE.
YOU GUYS SEE THE GRANDMAS RIGHT
THERE, THAT'S SPICY ANGEL.
UNDER.
HE IS BLOCKING.
THEY'RE TALKING ABOUT GEORGE
KITTLE.
SAYING HE'S GOING TO BE
BLOCKING.
SO SHOUTOUT TO YOU, SPICY ANGEL,
YOU, MY FRIEND, ARE WALKING AWAY
WITH 250 DK DOLLARS.
PLEASE PARLAY THAT.
>> MY GUY SPICY ANGEL, LET'S SEE
WHAT YOU CAN USE THOSE DK
DOLLARS ON, HERE'S GREG AND I'S
PROP PARLAY TICKET FOR PACKERS,
49 ERTZ.
YOU KNOW THE DEAL BY NOW.
WE'RE GOING OVER AARON RODGERS
PASSING YARDS, UNDER JIMMY G'S
PASSING YARDS.
UNDER DAVANTE ADAMS RECEIVING
YARDS, UNDER GEORGE KITTLE
RECEIVING YARDS.
SHOUTOUT TO DRAFTKINGS FOR
HOOKING US UP THIS WEEKEND.
GET YOUR SAME DAY PARLAYS LOCKED
BEFORE THE GAME STARTS.
MOVING ON, COMMUNITY COMMENTS,
CONTEST.
WATCH THE SHOW LAST WEEK, WE
ASKED YOU, AS PART OF THE SQUAD
RIDE, TO HELP WHICH QUARTERBACK
WAS THROWING FOR THE MOST
PASSING YARDS.
THIS WEEK WE GOT BACK TO OUR
ROOTS AND WANTED AN ANYTIME
TOUCHDOWN SCORE FOR THOSE OF YOU
THAT MISSED IT.
BUT, YOU KNOW THE DEAL BY NOW,
IF YOU RODE WITH US LAST WEEK,
YOU CASHED BIG.
WANTED TO ASK FOR YOUR HELP
AGAIN.
BEFORE WE GET TO SOME OF YOUR
FAVORITE RESPONSES, LET'S TAKE A
LOOK AT THE ODDS FOR THIS WEEK'S
PASSERS SO FAR.
WE'VE GOT TOM BRADY AT THE TOP,
PLUS 380.
MAHOMES, WHO WAS OUR BIG TIME
WINNER, AND BOOSTED UP TO PLUS
750 LAST WEEK.
SITTING AT PLUS 425 AGAINST THE
BILLS.
STAFFORD, BURROW, I'M A LITTLE
SURPRISED BY JOSH ALLEN AT PLUS
500.
I MIGHT HAVE SOME WORK TO DO
WHEN WE SHUT DOWN TODAY'S SHOW.
AND THEN, OF COURSE, YOU'VE GOT
RODGERS AND THE BIG TIME DOGS,
TANNEHILL, JIMMY G, THEY'RE BACK
THERE TO HAND THE BALL OFF.
SO WE PICKED TWO OF OUR FAVORITE
COMMENTS, AND WANT TO KNOW WHAT
YOU THINK.
GREG, I KNOW YOU'VE GOT YOUR
HANDS ON THESE.
WHAT ARE THEY LOOKING LIKE AND
WHAT DO WE NEED RIGHT NOW?
>> I NEED EVERYBODY TO GET IN
THE COMMENTS AND TELL ME WHICH
OF THESE IS THE BETTER TAKE.
I'M GIVING A HOODIE TO WHOEVER
YOU GUYS CHOOSE.
LET'S TAKE A LOOK AT THE FIRST
COMMENT FROM AK 47 BIG BLUE.
SAYS TITANS SECONDARY HAS BEEN
IFFY AT TIMES AND RIGHT NOW,
BENGALS ARE SO HOT, GOT TO GO
WITH JOE BURROW.
PS, THE BENGALS WILL WIN.
CONNOR, YOU KNOW HOW UH FEEL
ABOUT THIS.
WE GAVE OUT OUR PARLAYS AND THE
BENGALS MONEY LINE WAS ON MY
TICKET.
TALK TO ME.
TALK TO ME NICE, CONNOR, DO YOU
SEE THIS HAPPENING TODAY?
>> SHOUTOUT TO ASHER, FOR THE
PS, THE BENGALS WILL WIN.
WAY TO PUT IT ON THE LINE.
I LIKE THIS COMMENT.
I LIKE THE BENGALS.
I DON'T KNOW IF JOE BURROW IS
GOING TO TAKE HOME THIS TITLE,
BUT I THINK IT'S A REALLY GOOD
ARGUMENT.
HE'S GOT A GOOD ONE.
HE'S GOT JA'MARR CHASE.
HE'S GOT T. HIGGINS.
THE TENNESSEE SECONDARY, LIKE
YOU SAID, THEY DON'T SCARE YOU
TOO MUCH.
THEY REALLY DON'T.
THIS IS A BIG TIME CONTENDER.
WHAT ELSE WE GOT HERE FROM THE
COMMENTS, GREG?
>> CONNOR, THE NEXT ONE, LET'S
SEE THE NEXT COMMENT, IS FROM
BIG MIKE 13, I THINK BIG MIKE IS
IN THE COMMENTS RIGHT NOW, BIG
MIKE SAYS I'M SEEING JOSH ALLEN
READY TO SHOW HE BELONGS WITH
THE ELITE QUARTERBACKS, AND
AFTER LAST YEAR WITH DIGGS
WATCHING THE CELEBRATION,
CONNOR, THEY ARE READY TO EAT.
I KNOW YOU'RE FROM NEW YORK,
CONNOR, I KNOW YOU ARE FROM NEW
YORK.
YOU ARE FEELING THIS ONE, BRO?
ARE YOU THINK THE BILLS ARE
READY TO EAT?
>> BIG MIKE IS ALL OVER IT, AND
THIS IS COMING FROM A NEW YORK
JETS FAN AND THAT JUST MEANS I
KNOW HOW REAL THE BILLS ARE, HOW
REAL JOSH ALLEN IS, THIS IS SPOT
ON.
THIS IS BOLD.
HE'S PLUS 500.
THIS ISN'T A CHALKY PICK.
READY TO SHOW HE BELONGS.
HE IS ELITE.
BUT A WIN AGAINST THE CHIEFS AT
KANSAS CITY WOULD ESTABLISH IT
AS A LOCK.
I LIKE THAT CALL BACK ABOUT
STEFON DIGGS.
THEY'VE BEEN THINKING ABOUT THIS
FOR A LONG TIME.
THEY'RE GOING TO BE READY TO GO,
GREG, I LIKE THIS ONE A LOT.
>> YES, SIR.
YOU LIKE THIS ONE.
AND GUESS WHAT, I LIKE DOING
CONNOR, GOING TO THE HANDY DANDY
iPAD, THIS IS WHERE I GIVE
PEOPLE HOODIES, THIS IS WHERE I
GIVE PEOPLE JERSEYS, WHERE I
GIVE PEOPLE $250 TO GO PUT IN A
PARLAY.
IT GETS NO BETTER THAN THE HANDY
DANDY
DANDY iPAD, AND BIG MIKE, GUESS
WHAT, BIG MIKE IS IN THE
COMMENTS, HE'S ROCKING WITH JOSH
ALLEN.
BIG MIKE, YOU ARE WALKING AWAY
WITH A HOODIE.
YOU'RE WALKING AWAY WITH A
HOODIE, BIG MIKE.
HE'S IN THE COMMENTS RIGHT NOW,
CONNOR.
SO I'M JUST GOING TO CALL IT.
I'M GOING TO CALL IT, RIGHT
HERE.
BIG MIKE, YOU'RE IN THE COMMENTS
RIGHT NOW, SO THEREFORE,
BROTHER, YOU ARE A BIG FAN OF
THE SHOW.
YOU ARE RIDING WITH US, YOU SENT
US YOUR COMMENT BEFORE THE SHOW.
YOU'RE IN THE COMMENTS RIGHT
NOW, AND THEREFORE I AM SENDING
YOU TWO HOODIES -- NO, ACTUALLY
I'M SENDING YOU A HOODIE, AND
I'M GOING TO SEND YOU SOME DK
DOLLARS, BRO, WOUG AWAY WITH DK
DOLLARS.
>> BIG MIKE IS CLEANING UP RIGHT
HERE.
>> ACTUALLY.
>> TAKE IT AWAY.
>> ACTUALLY, HOLD ON, HOLD ON, I
JUST GOT WORD, I JUST GOT WORD
THAT MY GUY BIG MIKE, YOU'RE
ACTUALLY WALKING AWAY WITH SOME
AIRPODS, WITH THOSE AIRPOD MAXES
THAT I WISH I HAD.
I DON'T EVEN HAVE AIRPOD MAXES.
>> OH, MAN, CONGRATS TO BIG
MIKE.
WE APPRECIATE YOU SUPPORTING,
WE'RE SENDING YOU THE AIRPODS
AND WE GOT THE HOODIE, MORE
HOODIES, JERSEYS, DK DOLLARS,
AND AIRPODS MAX TO GIVE AWAY.
THEY HELP PEOPLE LIKE ME THAT
DON'T STAY IN THE EARS, CLIP
OVER THE EARS.
KEEP IT UP IN THE COMMENTS,
BEFORE WE MOVE ON TO OUR BOLDEST
BETS.
WE GOT SOMETHING SPECIAL IN
STORE FOR YOU GUYS.
AS YOU KNOW, ONE OF OUR FAVORITE
PROPS TO RIDE, ALL YEAR, WE DID
IT, FOR MONDAY NIGHT FOOTBALL,
EVERY SINGLE WEEK HAS BEEN THE
NO SCORE FIRST DRIVE.
BUT IT'S THE PLAYOFFS.
SO OUR FRIENDS AT DRAFTKINGS ARE
SPICING THINGS UP A BIT FOR US
THIS WEEK, GREG, LET THEM KNOW
WHAT THEY GOT PLANNED.
>> THAT'S RIGHT, CONNOR, THE
QUESTION IS, THIS WEEKEND, WILL
THE OPENING OFFENSE SCORE IN THE
FIRST DRIVE OF THE BILLS/CHIEF
GAME TOMORROW?
ACTUALLY, TOMORROW, DRAFTKINGS
IS BOOSTING THE ODDS FROM PLUS
110 TO PLUS 150.
CONNOR, I'M EXCITED ABOUT THIS.
I'M NOT EVEN GOING TO LIE.
I'M EXCITED ABOUT THIS ONE
BECAUSE I SAID -- I SAID THIS
ONE'S GOING TO BE A SHOOTOUT,
CONNOR.
YOU SAID THIS IS A SHOOTOUT.
I'M ROCKING WITH, YES, I THINK
THEY'RE GOING TO GO OUT AND
START THE SHOOTOUT -- GET THE
SHOOTOUT GOING FROM THE
BEGINNING OF THE GAME.
I'M ROCKING WITH A YES.
WHICH WAY ARE YOU LEANING,
CONNOR?
>> I'M WITH YOU ALL THE WAY.
I LOVE THIS BOOST.
RIGHT, THE PLUS 110 IS NICE AS
IT IS, PLUS 150, I THINK THE
TEAMS KNOW, COMING INTO THIS
GAME.
ESPECIALLY IF THE BILLS GET THE
BALL ON THE ROAD, AND THEY START
OUT WITH A BALL, YOU HAVE TO
SCORE.
YOU HAVE TO DICTATE THE PACE OF
THIS GAME.
YOU CAN'T BE PLAYING FROM
BEHIND.
NEITHER TEAM CAN PLAY FROM
I KNOW THEY GOT THE QUARTERBACKS
TO DO IT, BUT, LISTEN, THEY'RE
GOING TO BE VERY DESPERATE,
GREG, I THINK THEY'RE GOING TO
BE TAKING RISK.
I THINK THEY'LL GO FOR IT ON
FOURTH DOWN, ESPECIALLY ON THE
OTHER SIDE OF THE 50.
I LOVE THIS BOOST.
I'M GOING WITH POINTS AS WELL.
ARE THE PEOPLE GOING WITH
OPENING POINTS AS WELL?
>> HANDY DANDY iPAD.
>> THERE IT IS.
I GOT BEN, BEN SONK 619, YOU
GUYS SEE IT RIGHT THERE.
HE SAYS, YES, YES, YES.
ALSO, UNDER HIM, SEE BIG BEAT,
YES, SCORING WON'T STOP.
CRAZY ALL DAY.
SHOUTOUT TO YOU TWO, YOU ARE
WALKING AWAY WITH HOODIES.
YOU GUYS ARE WALKING AWAY WITH
HOODIES.
CBB, C BIG B, YOU'RE WALKING
AWAY WITH A JERSEY, WHY NOT?
>> GREG IS SWITCHING UP ON HIM.
HE'S LIKE, HEY, A HOODIE, NO,
YOU GOT A JERSEY.
THAT'S A BIG WINNER, AND GREG
AND I ARE HOPING TO BE BIG
WINNERS.
IT IS BOLDEST BETS TIME.
THIS IS WHAT WE WAIT FOR.
WIN OR LOSE, DON'T CARE, KEEP
FIRING AWAY.
OLDEST BETS TIME, GREG, I KNOW
YOU GOT HOODIES, JERSEYS, STILL
MORE DK DOLLARS LEFT.
TELL THE PEOPLE IF THEY'RE NEW
THIS TO BY NOW.
IF THEY HAVEN'T BEEN HANGING
WITH US FOR AN HOUR, WHAT
THEY'VE GOT TO DO TO GET IN ON
THE ACTION FOR OUR BOLDEST BETS.
>> KEEP IT SHORT, SWEET AND
CONCISE.
LET US KNOW IF YOU'RE ROCKING
WITH ME OR IF YOU'RE ROCKING
WITH MY BOY CONNOR OVER THERE,
BUT CONNOR, LET'S GET TO IT,
BRO, LET'S NOT STALL ANY MORE
TIME.
WHAT'S YOUR TAKE, BRO?
>> GREG, I GOT A LITTLE OUT OF
CONTROL THIS WEEK, I SAW THE
DRAFTKINGS, PICKING ANYTIME
TOUCHDOWN SCORE.
EVERY PARLAY, GET IT BOOSTED
25%.
HERE IT IS.
BENGALS, TITANS, JA'MARR CHASE,
PLUS MONEY, OKAY, DAVANTE ADAMS,
OUR SQUAD RIDE LEADER, I DIDN'T
KNOW THAT YET, DAVANTE ADAMS,
COOPER KUPP THE RUNNER-UP FOR
SQUAD RIDE LEADER AND THEN DEVON
SINGLE TARRY, HE GOES BY THE
NAME OF MOTOR AND HE'S GOING TO
MOTOR HIS WAY INTO THE END ZONE
ON THE CHIEFS HOME TURF.
PLUS 1575.
THAT IS RIGHT.
SPRINKLE A LITTLE BIT OF MONEY
ON THIS.
GET CRAZY.
OR THE FIRST TWO HITS TODAY, IF
YOU'RE SCARED, DON'T BE SCARED,
YOU CASH OUT TOMORROW MORNING
AND GO BUY YOURSELF AND YOUR
LADY OR WHOEVER IT MAY BE, A
NICE BREAKFAST.
GREG, WHAT ARE YOU GOING WITH
FOR BOLDEST BETS THIS WEEK?
>> THAT WAS REALLY BOLD, CONNOR.
THAT WAS EXTREMELY BOLD.
>> FINE LINE BETWEEN BOLD AND
STUPID, MY FRIEND.
>> I'M GOING TO BE A LITTLE
BOLD.
ACTUALLY, I'M GOING TO BE BIG
BOLD RIGHT HERE.
I'VE BEEN TALKING ABOUT THE
BENGALS.
SHOW, IT'S NOT GOING TO STOP,
CONNOR, I'M ROCKING WITH THE
BENGALS, CHECK THIS ONE OUT,
CONNOR, ALTERNATE SPREAD,
ALTERNATE SPREAD, MINUS 4, I SEE
THE BENGALS GETTING THIS WIN,
AND IT'S NOT BY A FIELD GOAL,
CONNOR, IT'S BY MORE THAN THAT.
SO GIVE ME THE BEN GALS MINUS 4.
>> GREG, LIKING THE UNDERDOG TO
WIN BIG, GREG, WIN BIG.
>> YES, SIR.
>> I LOVE IT.
GO.
>> YES, SIR, YES, SIR.
I THINK THE BENGALS GO TURNED UP
TODAY, THEY'RE GOING TO TURN UP,
OFFENSE IS GOING TO SHOW OUT A
LITTLE BIT, AND THE TITANS, WE
JUST DON'T KNOW WHICH VERSION
WE'RE GETTING, THE DERRICK
HENRY, RUNNING THE BALL 20
TIMES, OR ARE WE GOING TO GET MY
GUY TANNEHILL TRYING TO CONNECT
WITH A.J. BROWN, CONNECT WITH
JULIO.
I JUST DON'T KNOW, IT'S SO MANY
QUESTIONS ABOUT THAT TITANS
TEAM, I'M ROCKING WITH THE
BENGALS.
>> BIG TIME GIVEAWAYS.
WE WANT TO KNOW FROM THE PEOPLE,
AND GREG'S GOING TO CHECK IN,
ARE YOU RIDING WITH ME?
ARE YOU RIDING WITH GREG?
ARE YOU RIDING WITH YOUR OWN
BOLDEST BETS?
DON'T BE SHY.
GREG, WHAT DO THEY GOT FOR US
RIGHT NOW?
>> CONNOR, I THINK VEGAS IS
CALLING ME RIGHT NOW.
I THINK THEY'RE TRYING TO GIVE
ME A LOCK.
BUT, BUT I'M GOING TO THE
COMMENTS.
I'M GOING TO THE COMMENTS AND
I'M GOING TO GIVE AWAY SOME
HOODIES AND SOME DK DOLLARS.
I GOT -- LET ME SEE.
I GOT NY 22 GC SAYS BOLD AND
BEAUTIFUL BET, CONNOR, TAKING
THIS ONE, GREG.
I DON'T KNOW WHO THEY'RE RIDING
WITH, CONNOR, BUT SHOUTOUT TO
YOU, YOU'RE WALKING AWAY WITH A
HOODIE.
ALSO I GOT CITY 3184 SAYS WHY
NOT BOTH, I LOVE THAT ENERGY.
I LOVE THAT ENERGY.
I'M SENDING 250 DK DOLLARS TO
YOU.
>> SO SHOUTOUT TO YOU.
THANK YOU, GUYS, THANK YOU,
GUYS.
FOR COMMENTING AND SHOUTOUT TO
EVERYBODY THAT I MENTIONED.
IF I MENTIONED YOU, YOU'RE
WALKING AWAY WITH A HOODIE OR
250 DK DOLLARS.
>> GOOD VIBES IN THE COMMENTS
DURING BOLDEST BETS.
AND WE'RE GOING TO KEEP THEM
ROLLING.
BECAUSE IT'S TIME FOR A LITTLE
GRAND PRIZE GIVEAWAY.
YOU HEARD ME MENTION IT.
NOT THAT LONG AGO.
WE GOT THE AIRPODS MAX GIVEAWAY
ON TAP.
WE'RE LOOKING FOR SOMETHING
SIMPLE.
BUT SO COMPLEX.
BEST BETS TO WIN THE SUPER BOWL.
THAT IS RIGHT.
LET'S TAKE A LOOK AT THOSE SUPER
BOWL ODDS AS IT STANDS RIGHT
NOW.
THE GREEN BAY BACKERS AT THE
TOP.
CHIEFS, BILLS, AND THE REIGNING
CHAMPS GETTING A LITTLE
DISTHERE, PLUS 550 FOR THE BUCS,
RAMS AND TITANS WHERE THE BIG
UNDERDOGS COME IN, 9ers AND THE
BENGALS WHO YOU ALSO LIKE,
GETTING ZERO LOVE, REALLY ALMOST
DISRESPECT AT THIS POINT, ALL
THE WAY AT THE BOTTOM.
GREG, LET THEM KNOW WHAT THEY'VE
GOT TO DO IF THEY WANT TO GET IN
ON THE ACTION FOR THESE AIRPODS?
>> HEY, IF YOU GUYS WANT TO GET
IN ON THE ACTION, TELL ME YOUR
LOCKS TO WIN THE CHAMPIONSHIP.
WE'RE GOING TO SPIN THE WHEEL.
AND IF YOUR COMMENT MATCHES THE
TEAM CHOSEN BY THE WHEEL.
YOU COULD WIN A PAIR OF AIRPODS
MAXES.
>> IT'S PRETTY SWEET.
PRETTY SWEET DEAL.
>> THAT IS.
>> I'M GOING TO DROP MY BET.
MY BET HERE, I SAID IT EARLIER.
I STILL HAVE A PACKERS TICKET.
I KNOW THEY'RE THE FAVORITE ON
THAT BOARD.
WHATEVER.
CHALKY PICK.
I LIKE THE PACKERS.
YOU CANNOT PREDICT THE WHEEL.
LET ME SAY THAT.
THE WHEEL IS NOT GOING TO TAKE
THE FAVORITE OR BY DEFAULT.
GREG, YOU HAVE A FUTURES TICKET
LEFT, NOT A FAVORITE RIGHT NOW.
WHAT DO YOU GOT RIGHT NOW?
>> CONNOR, EVERYBODY KNOWS I'M A
49er FAN AND BROTHER I HAVE ONE,
I HAVE A 49er FUTURES TICKET.
I HAVE A FUTURE 49ers TO WIN THE
NFC, I HAVE A FUTURE TICKET FOR
THE 49ers TO WIN THE NFC AND A
FUTURE TICKET FOR THE 49ers TO
WIN THE SUPER BOWL.
SO HOPEFULLY I'M CASHING,
BROTHER, HOPEFULLY I'M CASHING.
AND HOPEFULLY I'M GETTING RICH.
AND IN FEBRUARY.
>> THAT'S RIGHT.
ALL RIGHT, GREG, IT'S TIME TO
SPIN THE WHEEL.
IF YOUR PICK MATCHES THE WHEEL,
YOU CAN WIN A PAIR OF AIRPODS
MAX, THAT WILL DEPEND ON HOW THE
COMMENTS GO.
LET'S SPIN IT.
GET THIS THING GOING, AND
ROLLING, IT'S GOING TO GO FOR A
WHILE HERE.
GET IN THE COMMENTS, GET GOING,
GET FIRED UP.
MAKE YOUR PICK.
LET'S SEE WHERE WE LAND.
>> LET'S SEE WHERE IT GOES.
LET'S SEE WHERE IT GOES.
IT'S TURNING, IT'S TURNING, AND
IT IS -- PASSING THE 49ers.
OKAY.
TITANS.
>> TITANS.
THE WHEEL HAS SPOKEN.
AND THEY ARE GOING WITH THE
NUMBER ONE SEED, THAT IS THE
TITANS.
ALTHOUGH THEY ARE NOT NUMBER ONE
ON THE ODDS BOARD RIGHT NOW.
WHOO, WHO'S TAKING HOME THOSE
AIRPODS MAX TODAY?
WHO HAD THE TITANS?
WHO IS FIRED UP RIGHT NOW, GREG,
DO WE HAVE A WINNER?
IS THERE ANYONE IN THERE?
>> CONNOR, I AIN'T EVEN GOING TO
LIE, MAN, WHAT THE TITANS?
OH, WAIT, WAIT, WAIT.
I GOT ONE.
KING OF SPORTS 21.
ONE OUT OF THE MANY TITANS GOING
TO WIN IT ALL.
THEY GOT ALL THE OFFENSE WITH
KING HARRY.
GOT TO GO WITH THESE HIGH ODDS.
AND WINNING COACH OF THE YEAR.
THIS IS THE YEAR FOR THE TITANS
TO WIN IT ALL.
THERE IT IS.
CONNOR.
THERE'S THOSE AIRPOD MAXES,
THEY'RE GONE TO MY GUY KING OF
SPORTS.
SHOUTOUT TO YOU, YOU'RE WALKING
AWAY WITH THE AIRPOD MAXES.
IT'S TIME TO GO.
I'VE GOT TO GO.
WE'RE DONE HERE, YOU KNOW THE
DEAL, THOUGH, WE'LL BE BACK.
CONGRATS TO THE WINNERS.
KING OF SPORTS, BIG WINNER, I
DIDN'T THINK WE'D HAVE SOMEONE.
I THOUGHT YOU OR I WOULD HAVE TO
PLAY ROCK PAPER FOR THOSE
AIRPODS.
THAT WOULD HAVE BEEN FUN.
CUSTOM BOOTS, YOU SAW THE PROPS.
GET IN ON THE PARLAY.
BET DAVANTE ADAMS PLUS 100.
YOU'D BE A FOOL RIGHT NOW NOT TO
THROW A LITTLE BIT ON THAT
ACTION.
DRAFTKINGS, $5 TO WIN $280.
A GREAT DEAL FOR NEW USERS.
GET IN ON THE MONEY LINE ACTION,
YES TO SCORE ON THE FIRST DRIVE.
BILLS CHIEFS BOOSTED TO PLUS
150, FROM -- NUTS, NUTS.
THIS IS -- I DON'T WANT TO SAY
FREE, BUT THIS IS FUN MONEY.
FUN ODDS BEING SPREAD AROUND.
>> YES, YES.
>> YOU KNOW THE SAME GAME PARLAY
PROMO RIGHT NOW.
PLEASE SEND US YOUR REACTION
VIDEOS THIS WEEKEND AS THE GAMES
GO ON, ESPECIALLY IF YOU'RE
ROOTING FOR ONE OF THESE TEAMS,
IF YOU'RE ROOTING FOR SOMEBODY
THAT YOU BET ON, SEND THE
REACTION VIDEOS.
MAYBE WE'LL THROW IT IN THE
SHOW.
WE WANT TO SEE THE REALTIME
TAKES ON SOCIAL IN THE B/R
SPORTS BETTING COMMUNITY STREAM.
JOIN US NEXT SUNDAY AT 11:00
A.M.
YOU'RE GETTING USED TO THESE
SATURDAY AFTERNOONS, WE'VE BEEN
CHILLING.
GIVES GREG AND I SOME TIME TO
GET COFFEE AND BREAKFAST AND
SHAKE A HANGOVER.
WHATEVER IT MAY BE.
SUNDAY, WE'RE BACK NEXT MORNING.
WE'LL BE GOOD TO GO.
THANK YOU SO MUCH, EVERYONE, I'M
CONNOR ROGERS, GREG IVORY.
WE'LL CATCH YOU NEXT WEEK.
♪